a terrible problem
that afflicts many of us is that we are
almost permanently
anxious self-critical self-hating and
afflicted by a sense that we don't
deserve to exist
we are definitely not good enough ever
psychology points us to a part of the
mind termed
our conscience a faculty that keeps an
eye
on how well we're doing in relation to
duty
to the demands of the world and to the
regulation of our desires and
appetites our conscience monitors how
much effort we're putting into our work
and our ratio of relaxed rest to anxious
labor it's our conscience that tells us
when we've probably done enough
gaming dating or eating however useful
this function may sound
for many of us our conscience has grown
very
unbalanced rather than occasionally
gently nudging us towards virtue
it is permanently screaming denigrating
and attacking us
for perceived failings it tells us that
nothing we do is ever good enough
that we have no right to take a holiday
let alone an afternoon off
that we have no business relaxing or
enjoying ourselves
and that the worst is coming to us
because of our sinful nature
anxiety and self-contempt are our
default states
it was freud's simple but brilliant
insight that our conscience is formed
out of the residue of the voices of our
parents
in particular usually of our fathers
freud called the conscience the super
ego
and proposed that this faculty continues
to speak within our minds
as our father figures once spoke to us
for the lucky ones among us we had
reasonable father figures
and therefore our consciences are
broadly benign if we fail today
we can try again next time if we're
unpopular we can be valuable
anyway we deserve a rest sex is allowed
treats are a part of life we can do
nothing for a while
we're okay as we are but for others
among us
our conscience rehearses the worst lines
of punitive parental archetypes
when things go wrong we swiftly conclude
that it might be better
if we killed ourselves one of the steps
we can take towards greater mental
health
is to realize properly realize that this
drama is going on inside us
it sounds strange to say given the
significance but usually
we have no clue the self-criticism has
become too familiar
to be noticeable it's just how things
are and who we are
we can't draw a distinction between the
fierce inner critic
and any other part of us a crucial first
move
is therefore to learn to put some
distance between ourselves
and our conscience we should see our
conscience as
a character we should tell ourselves i
have a punishing inner critic
and it's very unfair to me it's even
sometimes trying to kill me
it's speaking to me within me but it
isn't all i am
it's someone i sucked in from childhood
and might learn to expel from my mind
in time we can then start to question
the critic
is it really fair to say that our lives
are wholly worthless
we've messed up for sure but do we
really deserve no compassion and no
forgiveness
is nothing about us in any way good
would we ever think of treating a friend
or even an enemy the way we're treating
ourselves
we had no choice about who we had to
listen to when we were little
but we do now have agency we can
retrain our minds by getting better at
spotting how they were indoctrinated in
the first place
we have picked up some extremely cruel
and questionable habits
no one needs to be hounded by a sense
that they are excrement
this feeling has a past and it doesn't
have to be the future
to retrain ourselves we need other
people
people who can love us and fill our
minds with other
kinder perspectives we need to dare to
lean on them
not an easy move for people who feel
undeserving in the first place
and ask for their help in taming the
nasty soundtrack inside
we should stop trying to be brave about
the inner attacks we host
we might explicitly say to others you're
here to help me with my inner critic and
to give me new perspectives
on my self-punishment and despair we
should at times get incensed
that we have to live with such a critic
and question why our first impulse
is so often to forgive the critic and
the parental figure who inspired it
and blame ourselves for our stupidity we
need to feel sorry for ourselves
and annoyed with those who didn't know
how to show us tenderness
of course we occasionally need to
upgrade ourselves and try harder
but the real achievement is to know how
to remain
gently and generously on our own
side
self knowledge is a new essay book that
takes us on a journey into our deepest
most elusive selves
and arms us with a set of tools to
understand
our characters properly